hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay
y'know we've got a very obvious trap
here and I'm not gonna bring it just yet
not gonna do that
I'm gonna do that huh huh huh huh who's
out here huh
wha huh nothing oh wow this is actually
a big area it's a really big area feels
strange I can't go in there I literally
cannot go in here okay joy like I uh I
got plenty of oil ice all right
who's out there who wants some hey
anybody is seriously like a big place
I'm kidding man guys here small from ha
ha
oh no acid explosive liquid oh my
goodness
Oh
ah I thought I saw him in flickering the
flame there please walk it back here
move man come on come on come and get
some we get some yeah yeah gone that's
what I thought
ha ha ha ha what a dancer what a pansy
let's give me charity to borrow you for
a second
thank you very much see you know it
you're coming with me
you're very thick and body like that in
chair you look like you could support a
lot of weight if you'd know what I mean
ha ha ha
chair you so nasty hardware see do I
need to hide in here probably cuz that
monsters gonna come by I don't need it
like just wasting oil there cuz I'm an
idiot I'm a bug in a German yet yeah
okay anything in there no tear come with
me oh yeah I'm so bad chair
yeah no ha ha ha yeah Oh who's the other
end of the puzzle or the trap the very
obvious trap alright let's go let's go
sprang the trap chair
come on chair you will protect me right
right ah oh oh my god
what where oh my god are they behind me
ha ha get in there [ __ ] you ha ha ha
Oh No what ha ha
Oh No Oh close the doors close it close
all of them
still here they don't close all the way
leave whoa oh stupid flange flange get
up out of there
I swear flange oh my god I hate most
close it the same oh there he is
I saw him ah gonna close that door close
it close it
come ah hum ah come on one more
why am i locking myself in here I never
thought to ask why ah
oh it's closing themselves oh I'm an
idiot okay huh wah wah wah bah bah bah
not good not good okay
yep that's not good oh boy I still hear
the monster what lights went out
oh I'm here does he'll be okay there's a
light over there let's go this way
and normally marry blackness don't throw
anything at me don't throw anything on
me huh what what I I don't I didn't do
that I didn't ha I said not to throw
anything at me ha
okay I'm okay okay get up get up
Daniel Isaac I wanted to call you Isaac
for a second there get up Daniel come on
get your [ __ ] together are there so
monsters okay I got the flux key I can
open the hotel door the hotel door what
what I think what Oh
can I get out of here now is that the
only thing I needed to get in cuz I got
the explosive liquid measure all right
that doesn't open that rumbling okay I
guess I can't open that either
I picked all the wrong ones anybody home
oh hello aah
let me grab the rest of this oil perfect
there we are
mmm-hmm explode this blow it ah ah come
on ah what again
really you're an [ __ ] you're an
[ __ ]
game oh [ __ ] I forgot I wouldn't have
forgotten the fuse you douche odd set
thing they threw at me
don't throw another one don't do it
what's this I picked up a rock what what
what is that what what is this what did
I just pick up I picked up a rock I did
I need a rock what was the point of that
rock why do I have a rock okay I they've
been throwing things at me naked guys
and it's just not cool man don't throw
naked guys at people when they're not
ready cuz then they're not ready alright
anyway okay back here now I guess I can
go up a level to the hotel it's the next
level where the piano is
if that's a hotel it's kind of [ __ ]
aw come on yeah I'm an idiot the other
door was the same way I didn't use
anything on it I'm a big idiot loading
another big level I bet oh yeah
no kidding big level what's going on I
don't like this like a bar I was a
bartender I can work this no the flux
machine is the best way of locking
things out why you need to use the flux
key the square pipe flows directly to
the triangle but the triangle has two
ways of operating one to block the
system and one to flow the steam into
the air you need to divert the steam
into the circle the gate is still locked
you need the flux key to block the
system and unlock the gate okay so I
just jam the flux key in here what about
this orb whatever jam it in yep that
seems like a flux Keanu
hey it opens to my doom and pretty sure
it goes to my du
if I'm not mistaken because all roads
lead to my doom
yes the music concerns it anything under
the stairs northern Oh big big surprise
who's out here I'm ready for you I'm so
ready for you
brand on huh
chair good McNabb are you ha ha booyah
thank you very much anything no hitting
in here who's here Oh chair what
happened to you huh yet a little too
much to drink
aw don't be breakdancing haha I've had
enough of that nope nope nope nope
okay alright anything in here a bed a
haunted bed
nothing awful suspicious I guess it was
nothing whatever it's a hotel I think so
I guess it would have beds rooms so I
came in I thought I'd go in a circle
already oh I see cuz those stairs go up
hello anybody in here
anybody in here no open from the bottom
up cuz I'd be smart I don't think
there's anything in these rooms
maybe I mean I would be remiss if I
didn't check everything booyakasha chair
there's some screaming going on I want
to get to a safe place chair forget
about me think of yourself oh hello
chair i met your twin brother in the
other room over there alright there was
nothing these are just identical
do-nothing rooms but there's a staircase
here let's go up it guess I don't really
need my lantern it's awfully well lit
why's this floor wet someone wax it
recently
everything deserves a good waxing way
Kenny Wayne quaint wink hello that's
another one I'm gonna assume that
there's nothing else I know we all
chosen to block the Great Hall you think
alike
now you think like why you shoe Oh why'd
you should we block it no it's a living
horror movie
the floors are amazes with so much
darkest and black darkness and black
leaks so much people died in there we
didn't have much of a choice to block it
we call it the forbidden hotel floor now
this sounds like the worst place in the
world I have no choice to save David
who's David
it's give me you ha and I'm putting you
right way back chair I don't have time I
gotta save David whoever that is another
note was our notes on the tables
downstairs we all think about to block
the Great Hall with the big shelf to
unlock it there are three levers two in
each room the third level is stuck when
you found all levers and pulled the
third will be unstuck okay so there are
things in aa lever clunk okay so that's
one then the other one ah
so in the closet of each room there are
four rooms so one would obviously have
nothing in it looks like this is the one
let me just double check because there
is it there's a thing in here uh-huh no
no no no I don't see a lever oh hello
but this is kind of broken up ah no
lever here okay so it must be in the
downstairs ones and when I get one the
other will become unstuck
I guess cons plausible to me and this
hotel is rigged weird to keep some evil
out who would stay here anyway
it's simply a horrible place to say okay
wait a minute don't see a switch there
that means wait hang on
what I got a hunt around it's in a
different place phenomenal phenomenal
phenomenal sit I don't say everything
come on don't make me hunt around in
each room I've already looked
I've hour looked in his room oh these
puzzles hello anybody home
nothing nothing nothing nothing no note
on the floor switches which is which is
knife nothing nothing
stop swinging yeah nothing I'm racing
oil there's nothing
this man I swear I swear all right I'm
out of time I'll figure this puzzle out
in the next episode but thank you all so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you in the next part bye bye